從大盤局勢走到人生故事
從獲利停損到進場出場
我看過行情翻紅也看過希望落空
這裡不只是市場是我們的心理戰場
這裡是我交易過人生
哈囉大家好
歡迎收聽我交易過人生
我是凡爸
你現在收聽的是盤中告訴我的事
今天是8月4號現在是下午2點50分
好那今天凡爸的節目呢
最主要還是要分成兩個部分
那前半段是這個免費版的
免費版的話
就是把一些談美股的時事
幫你整理進來
那詳細的一些對大盤的看法
或者是族群的熱點分析
或者是我自己的一些操作的背後邏輯想法
我都會放在後半段的一個付費版
再跟聽眾朋友們做分享
但是今天的節目
還是完全整集都是免費可以收聽的
所以如果你覺得過去一段時間
已經聽煩霸的節目
聽到變成習慣了
如果盤中告訴我的這個系列
是對你過去一年來講
不要說過去一個月
但是如果說對你過去一年來說的
這個操作績效是有幫助的
那也非常感謝
也非常應該說
拜託各位聽眾朋友們
支持凡霸的頻道永續的經營下去
好不好
所以我們今天會在後半段
先跟大家說明一下
整個訂閱的一個制度的規劃
然後這個部分就跟大家共商一下
好不好
那也很感謝各位聽眾朋友們
蒼西來的支持
那我知道我只要做了這樣子的一個動作
訂閱以後
其實勢必一定是會有一些聽眾朋友
之後可能他們當然也就是會轉往其他的頻道
或是什麼的
那不管怎麼樣
我們都是誠心的祝福
也祝你的績效一路長紅
但如果你還是願意留在凡爸的頻道裡面
去跟著凡爸的想法去操作的話
那還是非常歡迎你
可以加入我們的頻道
好不好
那詳細的這個頻道怎麼訂閱的連結
到時候就是會放在下面
這個資訊欄的部分
所以大家就請特別要注意一下
正式訂閱的時間
我在禮拜五會給大家一個連結
到時候大家就請注意禮拜五的那一集節目
會有一個QR Code給大家掃一下
你怎麼去註冊帳號
然後怎麼去申請訂閱
好不好
好 先跟大家講一下
那我們今天先來講一下
就是整個上禮拜的一個狀況
台美股基本上我們在上禮拜五
迎來了應該算是台股的史上最大漲點
那當天台紫期3000多點了
台積電還被拉到漲停
連00981A這樣子的一個大型的ETF
他也是全面的鎖漲停的一個狀況出現
好
過去真的是沒有看過這樣子的一個事情
我也先跟聽眾朋友們說一下
這樣子的一個行情出現的時候
是不是代表整個行情是已經扭轉了
這個地方我會去看什麼
我就留在後半段的節目
跟聽眾朋友們說
好
再來就是禮拜四的凌晨深夜
FMC聯準會
他公布了他的利率決策
就一如大家的預期
就是他維持利率不動
但是這個地方在票數的部分
就是9比3
意外的出現了多了一位
有一個往傾向升息一馬的方向去走
所以感覺上乍看之下是有點偏硬
所以大家這個地方就是有點嚇到
所以當天這個利率決策完了之後
尾盤就殺下去了
所以美股就有一路大跌
好
這個地方就跟聽眾朋友們先說一下
在禮拜四的凌晨是這樣子
所以禮拜四的日盤
當天的日盤
就是非常震盪洗刷
可是當天的K線
其實有透露出一些小小的訊息
好不好
我們等一下後半段的話
再跟聽眾朋友們說
再來就是美股這幾天
我們可以看到軟體股
有轉強的一個狀況
我覺得軟體股轉強
就代表硬體已經是偏弱
過去一段時間
其實大家就會發現說
其實軟體跟硬體很少一起噴
大部分就是像一個翹翹板一樣
就是硬體因為一直砸資本支出
所以砸了一段時間以後
然後就開始有人突然發現說
是不是賺不回來
然後就開始就修正
其實所有的修正都是會有一個
總是會有一個故事
會有一個理由
所以這個部分其實就跟我們
不管是股票的上漲還是下跌一樣
它總是要有一個故事讓人去買單
那大家買單的程度
就根據他們的信心來決定
好
所以這個部分
其實就跟我們自己在日常生活中
不管是買車也是一樣
像帆婆跟帆爸的話
我們本來是在5月
還是4月的時候訂了一台這個賓士的電動車
那當時的想法是說
賓士應該不會差到哪裡去
但是呢
這個就想說
所以我沒看到車子也還沒進來
我們就直接先簽了訂單
跟業務就直接約好了
那結果呢
訂單也寫了以後
後來就開始陸陸續續呢
這個CLA的這個平台已經交車了
那我們訂的是GLC啦
是休旅車的
那10月才會進來
那時候我們想說應該不會差太多吧
因為它平台是差不多的
好
結果沒想到CLA在台灣交車以後
聽到蠻多的一些災情
那就影響了我們的一個信心程度
所以就開始覺得說
很擔憂這個車子交了以後
會不會出這個問題
出那個問題
而且畢竟買休旅車回來的話
就是要當家庭用車
跟帆爸自己的一個雙門跑車
就是不太一樣
全家一起通行代步
總是不能在路上叼車
所以信心受到的動搖
這時候我們就開始怎麼樣
開始在往別的品牌去看了
那就回歸了帆爸自己
最愛的一個品牌
就是BMW
一向就是以操控
或者是這種駕馭的體驗跟感受為文明的
那看了以後
我們後來想一想
不要賭太大
所以就決定最後還是把賓士給退掉
又回訂了這台休旅車這樣子
好 所以這也代表說
就是信心只要一旦潰散的時候
就算它是一個
大家都覺得口耳相傳很棒的一個車子
或者是品牌
但是我們還是在信心動搖耐克
選擇轉往一個相對比較安全的一個標的
所以事實上證明
我們在7月初的時候去福岡
那時候我們去租賓市
我們那時候租車也是租賓市
想說沒有買
那至少開開看吧
那開完以後完全沒有懸念
還好我們把它退掉了
那最主要的一個理由是因為
雖然內裝是真的比BMW漂亮很多
我們在內裝的部分
完全是無可比擬
這個BMW的內裝
就像是一台塑膠的感覺
但是賓市的內裝
就像是一個豪華夜店
所以氣氛 燈光都非常非常的棒
可是很可惜的就是
你畢竟那些電子配備
就只有停下來的時候可以摸
或者是晚上的時候才看得到
但是實際上你在路上的時候
最重要的還是你一個駕馭的感受
就是行路感
那我自己是覺得懸吊的系統
或者是它的加速油門的反應
跟我平常開的BMW也好
或者是保值節的一些慣性 調性
都實在是差距太大了
所以我們後來覺得還好我們換掉了
因為我覺得賓士還是偏舒適
而且那個舒適是有點太多了
所以講好聽就是舒適
講來那一點就是覺得他是軟趴趴的
就是懸吊那個吸震的那個能力
上下總是給我過多的一個起伏
那其實如果我一開始就先開賓市的話
應該不會有這樣明顯的感受
可是因為我一開始就是開賓的IPU
所以換過去的時候就會很明顯的感受到
兩個品牌的一個差異
好啦 所以當這個信心只要開始動搖的時候
本來不是這麼一回事
那我們就又開始把它當一回事了
OK 所以這是很神奇的一件事情
所以接下來就是和軟體股
它就變強了
但是這也代表就是說
其實這就是一個不斷的估值擴張
然後估值在修復的一個過程
所以有時候股價噴出去
漲出去以後
還是要去從一些角度
或者是面向來思考
什麼情況下你要去做減碼
我覺得這個是一個
蠻重要的一個事情
好 再來就是
在蘋果的這個電話會議
這其實執行長也特別聊到
就是說他覺得記憶體
這個上漲造成他們這些
消費電子有明顯的一個壓力
大家其實就可以發現
就是說其實這還是代表說
在記憶體這一個板塊
它還是非常非常的緊
缺跟應該算是看竅
所以這個供給很緊張
報價還是會持續上漲
所以我們也看到
在這一波的修正裡面
誰是最快趕快漲回去的
大家應該就知道
就是我們的DDR的類股
就是南亞克
好 再來就是因為近期
大家一直在找下跌的理由
大家就發現說
先前油價有一波突然飆升
目前來說
油價已經是成功的又回落了
所以對於通膨這件事情
大家擔心的應該算是疑慮
又暫時的消弭掉
不過目前我們還沒有明確的
可以看到台股有一個很強的上漲
所以油價已經回落了
可是在股價上面的反應
好像還是沒有出現
所以這個部分
我覺得我們後市
還是要繼續去觀察一下
好不好
所以從台股的一些籌碼
跟技術面來看的話
我們可以看到哪個板塊
現在這一波的修正裡面很強的
除了我們講的這個南亞科之外
還有一個部分就是在
這個台股的ODM這個大廠
其實ODM你去看它整年度的一個漲幅來說的話
其實你相比於其他板塊
比如說像ABF
或者是矽晶圓族群
或者是不管我們講的被動元件
就even它現在修正了那麼多
其實它的漲幅
還是沒有像人家那麼誇張
所以這也是它為什麼在這一波的修正裡面
它首先就是可以表態出去的
我覺得這一部分的理由也是因為
大家在這個時候想要買的是確定
而不是一個預期
所以我覺得在ODM這幾天的
這個強勢的上漲之中
我們大家也可以發現
就是資金就是往一些
相對來說比較保險一點的標的去防守
好不好
好
那這個地方
也後面就會連帶出一些反霸的
一些操作策略的想法
還有一個就是在昨天晚上
最新的一個消息
就是台灣終於把這個處置制度這個儲制它現在是變成半儲以前是全儲現在變成半儲從5分鐘一戳變成2分鐘一戳那我覺得這樣子的一個好處就是說
它釋放了一些流動性出來
那也讓這個做儲制策略的
這個應該算是大戶
或者是主力們
或者是我們一些會跟單的一些
不管是交易人來說
那其實策略全部都會重新洗牌
那之後就沒辦法看到
就是有一些常見的慣用的處置手法
所以這個部分
後面還會有什麼樣的交易機會
反正也會持續的再觀察一陣子
跟以前一定是長不一樣
因為兩分鐘一戳
以前是越關越大尾
如果碰到大盤不好的話
就是越關越變成什麼
變成隨位
變得很慘
對不對
有些就是跌到
就是一直被關一直被關的
對不對
所以像這一波像我們講說
比如說大量或監點
這種被關到很慘
或雍資科
這些都是非常非常非常淒慘的
其實都也是受到這個大盤的因素
再讓他們處置流動性的一個問題
所以這個部分也跟聽眾朋友們說
我們後續還是可以去
持續的去觀察一下
到底有哪些的交易機會
好 那在最後的
這個免費版的最後一段
我要跟聽眾朋友們說一下
就縱使上禮拜這個大盤
它是出現了一個
3000點的一個漲幅
那這個地方你說是不是就趨勢扭轉
要趕快把部位趕快全部打回來
這邊就要跟聽眾朋友們說一下
就是
我覺得在季限之下
你真的是不用太過積極的
去把整體的資金開的太滿
最主要原因就是因為
人家說
突然間那種暴漲的
有一點就比較偏向是
我們講說空頭的一個格局
所以這個地方
你也沒有說我們去預設立場
說他一定是要走空頭
只是說在這個地方
我覺得你還是跟著
貼著盤面的一個資訊
去下注你的部位
而不是說第一跟一起漲
馬上想要買在最低點
我覺得這樣子你去回頭看一下
其實蠻多個股都已經修正超過五成了
真的有需要在第一根就進去追
如果又碰到一個回馬槍
你又沒信心了
所以我會比較傾向這個地方
有辦法拿住股票
但是不要拿太多
後續你要跑也才跑得掉
不然你到時候部位全部一打滿
方向一挫
你又腳麻了
對不對
所以這個地方我還是跟聽眾朋友們說一下
就是一日的反彈
不見得是一個趨勢扭轉
我們還是要看後面的幾天
所以在這個之中
在趨勢確立的走出來之前
我們怎麼去控制水位
我們怎麼去做一些避險
這就是在一個全職敲議裡面
你必須要去思考的東西
所以我會跟聽眾朋友
我們在這個部分先這樣子說
好吧
以上的話就是我們前半段的節目
我們要進行到後半段了
後半段的話
我們要先來做一點工商
OK 大家就乱心的聽一下
好
先給大家看一下
這個是我們訂閱的一個規劃
我的規劃是這樣子
就是每個月會至少有6集的節目
盤中告訴我的事
每個月至少6集
代表說有時候一週會2更
到底這個一週2更的話
為什麼會2更呢
有時候盤面如果說
狀況很差的時候我會加開
所以有時候一週會是兩次的盤中
好不好
原則上一週一定至少1集
有時候看情況我會多加
比如說大盤特別強
或者是大盤特別差
我也都會在那個時候錄
好不好
所以就跟聽眾朋友特別講一下
我每週至少每個月一定是6集
好
這邊也跟聽眾朋友們完整的說明一下
當週如果是2集的話
凡爸會做一個小小的改變
就是上半段是免費版
下半段是付費版
對不對
但是如果當週2集的話
比如說禮拜二是上半集免費
下半集是訂閱
禮拜五的話
如果還是上盤中
我會整集都是付費才可以看的
好不好
所以先跟聽眾朋友們說一下
所以我們一個禮拜
基本上免費版只會有一集
好不好
免費版只會有一集
所以一週就算兩更
但是我免費版也只會有上半集
就是一週你只會看到一個
好不好
這樣聽懂我的意思
所以免費版的部分
一週只會出現一次
但是如果是付費版的話
最多一週會出現1.5次
這樣聽得懂我的意思了嗎
好 再來就是
我們看一下這邊凡霸
特別盤中告訴我的是
當然就是會講一些大盤的觀察
資金水位熱門族群 研究整理
還有我自己一些交易案例的思考邏輯
其實這些東西都不是在給各位一些
什麼明確的方向
要去買哪一支標的物
而是說你建立自己的交易框架
可以從別人的案例去想
你自己怎麼去思考這個市場的
其實凡霸自己有跟一些聽友交流過
他們過去聽凡霸的節目
已經聽了一年的
有一些已經成為
已經算是比較好的朋友的
有些操作的績效
都是非常非常的可觀
其實他們就是真的把
凡霸的一些觀念跟邏輯
貫徹到市場裡面去
好
再來就是像產業最新世界的
市場影響
這個都是還有下週留意的重點
方向
交易節奏風險
應對思考
好反正就是過去我們節目裡面
你會看到的一些內容
那我會把它做出一個明確的差異化
所以訂閱的付費完整版
就是每個月至少六集
如果當週有兩集盤中的話
免費版的聽友們很抱歉
我們就只有半集會給你聽
好 然後每一週的週末
我會出一篇會員的文章
那這篇文章的話
基本上就是針對各大型的ETF的持股
變化去做一些整理
然後會把他們重要的一些加減碼的
或者是現金流向去做一個觀察
然後反吧會做一些些自己的
應該算是操作的方向去想
我怎麼去想他這個變化是什麼
我們去做一些討論跟研究
那也不是很明確說
是跟你講說買哪個族群就對了
只是跟大家講說
我會把這些東西變成一段心得
然後變成是會員的文章
然後同時也會用文字稿的方式
把下週的重點跟觀察的方向
跟聽眾朋友們做個說明
那不定期的話
還會做一些交易的觀念跟筆記
所以每一週會至少有一篇
好不好
一篇的會員文章
那價格的部分的話
一個月就是988
那這個數字的話已經想了很久
那真的是
也盡量給各位聽眾朋友們
就是覺得有付出
也有收穫
好不好
好
那如果你是半年的話
就是96折
如果是年訂閱的話
就是9折
那我們這邊還要特別跟聽眾朋友們說一下
有一個很重要的 bonus
就是如果你今天是我們的會員頻道
的付費會員的話
會送你一個族群的
族群寶的
這不是AI生成錯誤
族群寶
不是族群石
AI還是有在進步
所以AI的發展空間還是很大
好不好
好
族群堡的工具網站
你只要在會員有效期間內
那你都是可以使用
都可以有使用權
所以它是不用額外付費的
所以這個族群堡
它是有點像什麼呢
它就是有很多很特殊的功能
那我這邊開給聽眾朋友們看一下
好 這是族群堡的一個網站
那基本上你現在
如果是沒有會員的話
你還是可以進來看
你可以看到一些很基本的
一些盤後資訊的整理好不好
這個網頁你還是看得到
但是你一定要成為會員的話
你才可以看到像這些個股的memo
那我們其實個股的memo
就是會把一些市場上很重要的
不管是相關的一個議題
或是什麼的
我們都會把它整理進來這個裡面
我都會把它整理進來
那這些東西都是給聽眾朋友們
就是做一個
不管是盤後
你自己在檢視很重要的一個
參考跟依據好不好
所以這邊跟聽眾朋友們說
這個一定要有會員
你才可以看得到這個東西
所以這個部分
我覺得是一個蠻大的亮點
好
那再來的話
還有一個就是
你一定要是會員才有的
古期儀標版
那這邊古期儀標版的話
我隨便示範一下
還有什麼好處呢
什麼厲害的地方
你可以在這個地方
直接輸入你的部位
現在權益數是多少
然後你買進了哪些標的
那假設啦
這只是假設
這不是真實的
假設我現在有15口
假設好不好
假設有15口的小台積電期貨
然後他就會幫你算出
你現在的市值多少
然後你持商價格
隨便key一個的好不好
大家不要想太多
好 那台光店
假設有6口
然後你key一個價格
那你就可以告訴你
現在的損益是多少
然後你現在用了保證金用了多少
使用率已經用到108%
已經超過了
槓桿是幾倍
他會幫你算出來
所以你總共的曝險
等於說你100萬的權益數
你已經曝險了653萬的市值
換句話講
你今天如果吃到一根跌停的話
那你的帳戶會直接少65萬
好不好
這個地方的意思是這樣
所以他可以每天的
把你自己的部位給輸進來
你就可以直接的很清楚
自己到底現在POOT險多少
然後我們有新增一個小工具
就是如果你要去做避險的話
這個避險你要買台紙棋
比如說你要做空
你要去SHORE
那你去SHORE的話
你要去SHORE多少
然後或者是說
你要去做賣權
買POOT
那賣權的話
假設你現在的權利金是多少錢
丟它是多少
你輸進去
下面就會有一個建議的避險口述
幫你算出來
這個算出來的東西
他就會告訴你說
你可能是一口大台
他就可以cover掉多少的一個市值
好不好
所以這邊就可以跟聽眾
就是你可以直接在收盤的時候
基本上我以前過去的慣例
都是在1點半收盤以後
看一下正利價差的一個狀況
然後我再去看一下
就是我現在曝險多少
那有沒有情境下是需要減碼
或者是去做一些避險的部位
尤其像近期的話
在季線下方
隨時會有一個回馬槍
1000點的這種夜盤蠻需要去做這件事情的以前過去都是用心算那現在就不用現這個工具就是你直接Key key進去你馬上就可以趕快的檢查出來你現在的狀況
你要用多少的避險部位
所以基本上
如果你要把交易這些事情變得很專業的話
這個網站是可以幫你蠻多的
至於什麼產業地圖
我不確定你們如果不是會員的
可不可以看得到
他也是可以看得到目前的板塊圖
那你也可以看到
就是哪個族群現在是最熱的
他全部都有幫你做一個分類
但是他這個都是盤後資料
盤中的話不會出現
所以你盤後做功課
他是一個很有用的工具
可是盤中的話
基本上還是要以你自己的一個看盤軟體為主
好
那回過頭來我們還是講一下
所以這樣子的一個工具
他最好用的地方就是
他是專門給交易者使用
就是我跟朋友KK
我們一起共同
就是我提供一些想法
那我就出一張嘴
簡單來講
就是他做比較多事情
他就把這個網站給寫出來
那只要是有在交易的人
這個網站就是
你只要是成為我們的會員頻道的話
那基本上就可以使用這個工具
而且是完全不需要任何的付費
那而且我們這個迭代的速度
非常非常的快
就是基本上
我煩怕自己想要看什麼東西
我跟KK講說
你可不可以幫我把這個寫出來
他馬上大概兩三天就可以弄出來了
所以基本上這個網站會一直更新
就是他更新他功能會一直增加
因為現在用AI做這些東西
速度非常非常的快
所以這個功能
疊代速度會比你們一般在市面上買APP
可能速度還要再快
所以這個部分也跟聽眾朋友說不用擔心
不會說送你一個
就是沒有在管理的東西
好不好
所以還是一樣
月訂閱半年訂閱好不好
那我想988
這6杯星巴克就可以了
6杯星巴克
那我相信如果說在過去一年多
你已經聽凡爸節目聽那麼久了
應該是有賺超過988塊
或者是說一年應該有賺超過10688
好不好
也支持一下凡爸的頻道
好 廣告時間就到這邊
然後呢
這個凡爸也順便講一下
就是凡爸自己在線上
這個申隊友有跟他共同開了一個課程
那這個連結我會放在這個下方的資訊欄
就是8月份14號一個線上直播課
7點到9點
那這個報名費用就是3780
OK 那基本上
我5月有做過一場
6月有做一場
都是線上直播的
其實我們的學員
基本上都
在過去的這兩個月都是順風順水
剛好7月沒開
7月就崩
8月如果有開會不會8月大漲
我們就共同來期待一下
報名的連結我一樣放下面好不好
像比如說5月
我們有講到低軌衛星這一塊
就是分析一下
這個整個產業的一些物理機制
然後在6月講先進封裝
所以有細晶圓 玻璃基板這一塊
7月剛好沒講
7月真應該去講的
不過7月沒開
是不是在暗示什麼事情
所以大家可以去搜尋一下
或者是下方的資訊欄
凡爸的動能直播課
這個月的話
應該會來針對特別是講水位的部分
去跟大家做一些講解
凡爸自己在調水位的部分
我是怎麼去做的
這個地方就有些跟聽眾朋友們
廣告工商到這邊
好
我們再來最後看一下
就是這個
好 我們就回到大盤的部分
來跟聽眾朋友們解釋說明一下
好不好
好 終於
這一根疊疊疊疊到這個地方
大家還記得這一條線的前面
是不是一個紅K的起漲點
對不對
這個我就沒有把圖完整的放進來了
就是大家應該都還記得這張圖
好
那大家會發現
在禮拜三的時候殺下來一根
第一次這樣有點小反彈
好 那禮拜四的日盤
衝上去 殺下去 衝上去
最後你會發現
他兩隻腳收的位置
都是在那一根
前面這個地方
紅K起漲的部分
他就守住了
所以這也是為什麼在禮拜四的時候
日盤出現了這樣一個狀況以後
我開始就在想說
我是不是要想辦法去塞一些多單
所以在這個地方
煩爸跟聽眾朋友們說
禮拜五的這一根三切點
煩爸是有扎扎實實的
有部位在裡面吃到的
為什麼呢
這個大家可以特別的去注意一下
這個地方
這個地方他在日盤的時候
殺下去最主要的理由
當然就是因為聯準會的利率決策
然後前瞻指引他取消了以後
就造成整個市場恐慌
好 那怎麼不給指引
以前都會給
現在不給了
不知道怎麼看
方向看不出來
可是他在這個地方殺下去
日盤殺下去以後
測試到了前破底點
又再次站回去
所以凡爸就覺得說
這個地方
我那天日盤是沒有做任何的單
可是在夜盤的時候
就開始塞了台積益
或者是像我們的胎子席
就有塞進去
好
那最主要的理由就是因為當天美股
他在晚上的時候就往上表態了
所以這也代表一件事情
就是有時候你在日盤看不出方向的時候
你在夜盤其實要塞部位
你可以塞全值的
可以塞大盤的
可以塞指數的
甚至有人塞0050期都有
前一天晚上就是給你做這件事情
所以在隔天開盤的時候
反吧完全不FOMO
為什麼
很多個股你基本上都買不到
但是沒關係
因為我前一晚在夜盤的時候
就有先處理進場的多單
OK
這個多單是用指數
所以有一般人過去不喜歡買台積電
不喜歡買指數
最主要一個理由
是因為覺得他漲幅不夠誘人
大家看一看
這漲幅不誘人
這個大盤超誇張
所以隔天個股
我只買一些快所漲停
還可以買的
只是它正價差稍微有點大
那我就有小買一些
哪些股票我就不特別多提了
今天還給我大跌的
好
那這個我先跟大家講一下
所以我那天是有去做
這樣子的一個部位
那但是到現在目前
我們可以發現說
這個反彈以後
到了這個地方
又是受到了這個均線的壓制
誰呢
季線跟月線
這兩支都還是在下彎
所以大家會發現
每次衝上去就好像過不去
衝上去就量就縮下來
就過不去
這個地方
我們當然是期待他明天
因為我看今天的尾盤
蠻多期貨都拉成正價差了
我在想說他們是不是整個市場
就是在猜
在賭
明天要直接跳空過
我在猜是不是這樣
不過反爸真的沒有把握
所以尾盤
我還是很惱的
看到他一翻紅
就去買了種了一點葡萄
這種如果過不去都死很慘
你知道嗎
就像這個
你看大家看一下
過不去
往下這個都很大根
你們知道嗎
過不去的這種往下都會很大根
所以凡爸在這邊上了一點葡萄
但是多單
我有小減
減碼的減
有小小的減碼的減
但是上了一點葡萄
這個地方如果不過
是明天又要苦了
但是我們當然是希望
明天就直接跳空過了
跳空過的話
我們就happy happy
Friday就可以開始慶祝一下了
是不是
所以目前我的佈局就是
只要這個沒有過
水位都不急著開
我在這個地方
所以我今天都還是有去做一些批
在尾盤只要一翻紅
我就跟那個朋友講到
就是說只要一翻紅
我一定會去上批的
一定要
為什麼
因為這個沒有過都會像這種
有沒有
你大家看
沒有過一大根
很恐怖
只要沒過的都很往下都很用力的
所以我在這個地方我不敢讀
我是寧可買點保險
所以大家如果有用到我們的族群堡
古旗儀表板
避險小工具
你就可以知道
如果說你650萬的部位
你買一個put要買幾口
可能買5口這個是情境避險
表示說比如說你持股跌5%的話
你要幾口才可以避掉
如果是跌3%
你對你的持股很有信心
有手的2%以內
你只要幾口就可以
或者是用市值的方式來避險
市值避險是最激進的
就是說假設全部跌停的話
你市值要完全避掉
你要四口的賣權
反正這個地方都會幫你算
你可以把它keykey
你就知道大概要算多少
所以反正在這個地方
有針對我的市值
去做了一些些的put
這個我們過去節目一直以來
也都是不斷的在貫徹這個觀念
好
那我們大家看一下板塊
這個地方我要跟聽眾朋友們說一下
我自己還是蠻喜歡誰的
還是蠻喜歡封測這個族群
縱使封測這個族群
今天萬宏從中一點綠
不過個人是覺得
龍頭這些東西還是可以多看看
好不好
龍頭還是可以多看看
因為畢竟他們的數字
或者是產業
這個不太會因為一天兩天的這種
什麼碰到季線碰到月線就改變了
所以我覺得還是可以多觀察一下
然後我們可以觀察到
就是上一集節目有跟大家特別聊到
就是光通這個族群
大家看一下
哇 這是聯雅 全新 穩帽
都好強
好
其實我就說了
其實光通這個族群
它的量已經出來了
在低檔的地方
右下角的量就已經出來了
很多人還是不敢買
這個地方通常會往上游去看
上游比較早發動的是比較好的
這個地方我目前光通的話
跟這個ESIC
我現在目前是壓在光通比較多
壓光通
我先跟大家講
為什麼光的邏輯是這樣
因為光的話
它的本益比其實比較高
或者像ESIC這種晶片股
他們的本益比其實也都很高那凡爸自己在想說在這種局勢不太好的情況下我高本益比的族群我不要壓太多所以我目前的想法是現在光這個地方如果光走的弱的話
我再回頭看一下ESIC
我或許把這邊做一點減值
會往ESIC去加
這是我目前的一個想法
是這樣子
所以目前的話
大家可以看到就是封測
昨天是綠的很強
紅的很普通
今天的話就反過來
但是我覺得整體來說
這個族群
它這樣子還是一個
應該算是有連動性的一個狀況
好不好
那這個地方也要跟大家講了
軍工今天的中光又漲停了
這邊翹翹板已經失去了
已經就一千錢是拉軍工
然後就會出這些大盤的股票
大全值
現在沒有了
他已經從上一波修正以後
這件事情脫鉤了
脫鉤就要把它拿掉了
好不好
就一陣子他會準
那不是永遠的好不好
市場哪有永遠的
對不對
以前1980年看的指標
1990年看的東西
跟2000年看的東西一定都不一樣
所以隨時本來就要去做更正
這個地方
這個部分
大家可以特別再去注意一下
這個跳跳板的部分
我覺得是已經目前沒有連結性了
所以大家就不用再特別去看
這邊還有一個比較有趣的事情
就是反吧這應該算是昨天
就是一直在判斷說
這個大盤如果在季線下方的話
要去做一些些的空方標的
去做一些Hedge就對了
昨天的想法就是說
針對有一個族群
我覺得這一波他怎麼談得這麼兇
在美股基本上是已經呈現腰斬的狀態
怎麼他現在還硬挺在這個位置
所以我就去空了一支DDR的漲停的股票
好
也跟聽眾朋友說
昨天在夜盤一開始的時候
我是很開心的
因為夜盤記憶體是大跌的
不管是Sandisk或者是美光
他們的表現都是疲弱的
結果沒想到昨天夜盤
居然可以從負1000點拉到
幾乎是平盤的一個狀態
除此之外
記憶體的美股全部都是翻紅
結果反爸就想說完蛋了
今天大概要開低的
可能要吃一個跳空3%或者是5%
結果沒想到今天記憶體
在一開盤的時候
居然還有盤下可以補
趕快撤退
因為看錯了
那沒賺到
結果還好撤退了
空單絕對不能凹單
你多單凹一下
問題都還不大
空單你只要被嘎到
瞬間就是差
成本就會離很遠
就會脫離成本很遠
那個感覺真的是會不好受
我就說我每次空個股
基本上那個個股好像都很難跌下去
自己過去的經驗
這也代表說
我們在講交易面來說
做多的難度跟做空的難度
做空還是比較難
原因就是因為做空的窗口
我覺得非常非常的窄
你去處理的時間
只有第一個時間
就只有第一
就是出事的當下
第一刻就要去處理
但是如果是多單的話
有時候凹一下
氛圍氣氛還在
你還有機會出場在一個相對漂亮的地方
但是如果是空單
基本上你都很安全下裝
所以我一直都對市場裡面
做空的人深感敬佩
真厲害
所以沒有吃到豆腐好不好
沒有吃到豆腐
但也沒有去轉手做多
因為覺得
有這麼多好股票可以買
我可能也不是會想要特別先去買它
你說本益比很便宜
其實69本益比也很便宜
或許可能這還比
我們講說這個記憶體的產業好一些
所以我自己的想法是
目前就先不往這個地方打
先不往這個地方打
後面再看吧
好吧 就先這樣
所以這是記憶體的部分
然後ODM還是很強
ODM其實他股票都蠻大的
然後你看
可以看微影漲4.3%
微創漲3.8%
這邊跟聽眾朋友們說一下
就是凡爸自己在上禮拜
沒有買到這個股票
就是有一些個股息都
一開盤就直接鎖死
沒有買到的
通常像針對像這樣子的一個情形
凡爸怎麼去處理
首先就是指數還是留著
而且你很難擔保就是說
到底當天這個大漲
晚上會不會又一根跌回來
所以凡爸當天的想法是說
沒萬一個股期能追到的東西我就追
但是最主要的部位
還是以盛虧跟這個圈值為主
然後當天的夜盤
凡爸就是也很怕就落賽
所以就往下設了一堆MIT
結果沒有想到在禮拜五的夜盤
當天晚上又給我跌掉1000點
所以我的胎子期全部沒了
胎子期全部沒了
全部被點出去
所以我在週末的時候
是只有禮拜五追到的那些個股期有流倉
水位是很低的狀況
我也是在想說
拜託
這個到底要不要大漲
結果看到禮拜天的時候
川普出一個新聞說
他怎麼樣
好像又taco了
對不對
我就開始擔心
我手上部位是不是不夠了
結果沒想到
這個昨天開盤的時候
運氣還不錯
有一些還是有開低給你買
所以有買到一些
哪一個族群
大家應該也都知道了
在這個板塊
大家可以看到這個圖形上面
應該是蠻明顯的
有一個板塊
應該也是過去一段時間
籌碼最擁擠的
大家都很喜歡的
好不好
大家都很喜歡的族群
我覺得不管怎麼樣
這個族群它是蠻確的
就是整個產業的一個趨勢
是蠻確立的
所以我跟聽眾朋友們特別說
如果我們在買不到部位的時候
通常我的想法就是
先從葉盤你可以交易的東西去下手
但是如果你又擔心
他突然間有一個回馬槍的時候
在夜盤可以處理的
也是那幾個標的
所以帆帕在禮拜五的夜盤
就是讓自己的水位
就突然間降得很低
禮拜一的時候剛好
就也開了算不錯的一個低價
就買到了一些些的個股期
不過整體來說
我現在的水位
目前都還是沒有開上去
就是目前還是壓在
比如說盤中
可能為了做一些些的日內
這幾天我覺得有變好做
比如說像今天有一檔
我送進去就上去了
就是馬上就瞬間有人買盤進來
那我自己有覺得氣氛有往好轉的方向去走
可是這個地方我也不敢去做流倉
所以日內就是日內結束
就是做到了就賺到了就出場了
不會特別想要去流倉
跟千千的氣氛還是不一樣
但是至少我覺得現在是敢去
在盤中日內的時候
去打一些多單的當從部位
所以這個部分也跟他講
就是我覺得氣氛在今天來看是還不錯
不過這個地方
我還是要跟聽眾朋友們說
整個交易的框架還是要建立在
目前大盤空單還是高達8萬口
8萬多口左右
昨天一度來到9萬口
然後再來就是整個
比如說像這個融資的水位
雖然沒有開上來
可是外資的回補
就是回補的力道
還是很明顯的不夠
然後最重要的是
大家會發現就是匯率
只要每一次台幣一扁的時候
那個大盤就會很呈現一個
應該算是賣壓就會很沉重
所以這個地方
如果我再沒有看到我喜歡的
那我也不會太積極
所以就算明天跳空一根上去
如果匯率沒有搭配的話
我也是不會把槓桿開回來的
就是因為這種有時候
大家如果去看格蘭幣法則的話
有時候那個反彈會過季線
反彈會過季線
讓你全部買回來
隔天又一根下去
所以我跟大家講
就是幾個因素全部都要達成
我給自己的條件是非常嚴格的
因為這一個段落
我覺得在處理部位的時候
最重要的事情是
不要吃到很大的draw down
但是又要想盡辦法把部位留在場上
我覺得這是最難的一個地方
所以目前我自己初步的一個規劃是
他就算站上了季線
用跳空的方式站
但是如果沒有看到匯率有明確的改善
或者是外資的回補力道是明顯的不足
或者是空單水位沒有降的話
我覺得我還是不會把水位開上去
或許就加一點點的多單
加個10% 20%的水位
但不會在這個地方還去做開槓
所以縱使他站上季線
我也不會只單看一條線
我還是要去看到多方的指標
真的有每一個都滿足我喜歡的
我才會去用力的槓桿
所以我也忍很久
也很想開槓
可是沒辦法
這個上天不允許的話
還是不要逆時
所以我們總是在
應該說在整個大盤這樣子
漲漲跌跌的過程
去加減調整自己的部位
自己做全職交易
大概也做了大概半年左右
我自己也跟聽眾朋友們說
這是一條不歸路
也不是一條很快樂的路
我不太能
就是把部位就放著不管
有的人是
如果說在今天上漲的時候
那當然就心情很好
但是我下跌的時候就不看盤
把APP關掉
然後這個我覺得
就是比較不像是面對工作
所以像煩爸自己的話
在如果碰到事況非常非常不好的時候
我其實會盯很緊
會把自己的部位
因為畢竟你把錢放在場上
你又不是來賭博的
你當然就是要來這個地方
盡量的去調整你自己的一個部位
所以跟聽眾朋友們特別說
就是我覺得自己在做圈子交易
其實發現他並沒有比一般的工作輕鬆
凡霸自己目前的想法是
邊做 自己也邊學
然後這條路真的是一條很不輕鬆的路
我也持續在這個頻道裡面更新一些
不斷我自己在交易的過程當中
累積的一些經驗
也期待在今年
還是可以看到大盤再度突破
就是新高
然後再創下5萬點
我們一起共同的期盼這件事情
也希望在明天的時候
大盤可以同時看到幾個好轉的跡象出現
那這樣我們禮拜五就可以開心的
就是上我們下一集的這個夫妻對象本
好吧
那先跟聽眾朋友們說一下
夫妻對象本上禮拜五的節目
還沒有收看的
麻煩你趕快去看一下
OK
好啦
那我們今天節目就到這邊
祝各位聽眾朋友愉快
掰掰
喜歡我的節目嗎
趕快追蹤起來
也趕快追蹤我的Instagram
btwtrades
還有更多進展內容不要錯過喔
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜